hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar reliable detection of
low abundance romatic mutations from
heterogeneous solid tumor samples I am
Judy I'll rock of lab roots and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab route the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
flame through collaboration and learning
it brought to you by Aegina bioscience
whether assessing sample quality
screening samples for actionable
mutations or enabling routine genetic
testing for tens to thousands of samples
a geno Biosciences products and services
help laboratories translate genomic
discoveries into mainstream clinical
practice let's get started this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits you can post questions to the
speakers during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them into the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green - and
a button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green join a button at lower left I now
present today's speakers Daryl Allen PhD
and Bobby call it Sutton PhD MD dr.
Erwin has been leading these scientific
services and application development
operations at Aegina bioscience in the
asia-pacific region and more recently in
global capacity for 10 years dr. Erwin
has a PhD from the University of
Queensland in non-invasive prenatal
testing he has authored more than 20
publications
numerous book chapters and holds several
patents dr. Sutton is future MD and PhD
from Indiana University followed by an
annotation
and clinical pathology residency at the
Roman grade school of medicine at Wake
Forest University in winston-salem North
Carolina and an additional year of
surgical pathology training at the
Medical University of South Carolina in
Charleston South Carolina
in addition to anatomic and clinical
pathology
she's also board-certified in blood
banking and transfusion medicine and
molecular genetic pathology she joined
the Medical Foundation in 2000 and
serves as the medical director of blood
donor services blood bank services and
molecular pathology please join me in
welcoming dr. Erwin he will now begin
his presentation thank you Judy
it's commonly agreed that the discipline
of molecular genetic testing is one of
the fastest evolving areas of today's
pathology and about evolution
particularly in the area of molecular
oncology is delivering tangible health
outcome improvements to our cancer
patients the rapid evolution always
comes with its challenges no longer do
we get large resection samples that
we're testing for maybe one biomarker to
assign to a single therapy in order to
provide greater access to targeted
therapies and to reduce adverse outcomes
we now get these tiny little tissue
samples that we need to analyze for
multiple biomarkers to select from
various therapies that may be effective
for these patients and if that's not
challenging enough we need to do this
quickly cost-effectively and most
importantly accurately not only is what
we're trying to achieve evolving but the
technology tool tools that we can choose
from to achieve these outcomes is
evolving equally as rapidly and today
I'm going to present to you a Gina's
latest evolution in technology allied
6hs chemistry and how this and the
panels that we have designed on this
chemistry can be used for reliable
detection of low abundance somatic
mutations from heterogeneous solid tumor
samples
so here are some of the challenges in
oncology listed in dot point as I said
before we have very small samples common
sample types include finally last
breaths then needle core biopsies where
there's only a small amount of tissue
available for analysis and in order to
do routine anatomical analysis these
small tissue samples are put into FFPE
blocks that highly degrade the DNA such
that we have highly variable and
degraded samples available for nucleic
acid analysis we want to analyze those
multiple different biomarkers so that we
can select from the various therapies
these tissue samples are not pure we
have this challenge of heterogeneity and
that is the amount of cancer cells that
are mixed in with normal cells in the
biopsy and within those cancer cells the
variability in the cancer itself the
various different clones that are
present now an invasive biopsy is rarely
repeated it's an invasive process with
its own risks and therefore it's a
single analysis of a section of a single
single tumor that is only a single point
in time so it doesn't cover the entire
metastatic disease now all of these
challenges do need access to a sensitive
and accurate detection technology such
as the mass array that is offered from a
gene of bioscience however we can
further break them down the first for
here our limited quantity our variable
quality our multiple analytes in our
heterogeneity can be improved by using
robust short amplicon technologies that
are highly multiplexed and use small
amounts of sample input such as Li Plex
HS biochemistry
so our iplex HS biochemistry allows us
to rescue critical samples samples that
wouldn't be able to be analyzed on
alternative technologies but now can be
analyzed on this robust short amplicon
highly multiplexed technology with low
input material we have very short
turnaround time our time from DNA to
result is less than 8 hours and a very
simplified lab process not a complex
multi-step process but it's
simple workflow that any general
clinical laboratory can follow and the
improvement in the chemistry itself now
allows us to get down to 1% allele
frequency detection allowing you to test
low frequency down low tumor content
samples and expand your are same menu
now it's not going to resolve all of the
challenges there will be a point where
heterogeneity gets so low that you don't
actually have to myrrh cells or the type
of tumor cell that you're looking for in
your sample the fact that it is rarely
repeated and difficult to track samples
as their disease evolves and the fact
that it's a single site won't be
resolved by just improving sensitivity
and robustness of both tissue biopsies
and really these challenges are the
opportunity to look at circulating tumor
DNA or circulating tumor cells to
improve and complement the clinical
workup now that isn't the the topic of
today's discussion we did present a
webinar last month on liquid biopsy
which you can access from the Agena bio
art and bioscience website in our
resources section and videos and
webinars and hear about how well liquid
biopsy panels can be used to detect
circulating tumor material down to 0.1%
frequency so that you can monitor
disease progression advanced therapeutic
research but moving back to our life
like a chess chemistry so our existing
chemistries chemistry's we have our
liquid biopsy chemistry called ultra
seek at a 0.1% mutation frequency limit
of detection and we have our standard
iplex Pro biochemistry and we're now
introducing our new iplex HF
biochemistry allowing us to detect in
solid tumor samples mutation frequencies
down to 1% so let me describe for you
the biochemistry workflow so starting
from just 10 milligrams of input DNA
coming from those fine needle aspirates
that have been been formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded of course other other
sample types are also able to be put
into this we have this short amplicon
pcr a multiplex PCR of multiple
amplicons
that is very short in its amplicon size
such that it's highly robust on
degraded template and here is an example
of a 1% mutant which is our 80 mutant
mutant nucleotide and 99% wild-type
being our CG we amplify that sample and
then we do a single base extension so we
anneal a primer adjacent to our position
of interest and we extend a single base
and with our life like a chess chemistry
we actually do a single base extension
that is enriched in efficiency for
generating the mutant product that is
that that extension on to the mutant
mutant termination base is is more
efficient than the extension on to the
wild-type such that we're driving down
our sensitivity so we are still
observing the wild-type however we're
increasing the frequency in the
biochemistry of the mutant such that we
can detect these low-frequency mutations
following the single base extension with
our newest instrument our chip prep
module that you can see in this third
box it's completely automated sample
conditioning transferring onto the
spectra chip and mass spectrometry
analysis so the Agena bioscience system
uses mass spectrometry as an as an
analyzer such that it's very quick
highly accurate because we're measuring
the unlabeled nucleic acid itself down
to its molecular mass and then finally
because it is mass spectrometry which
mass spectrometry delivers a very very
flat baseline highly specific sharp
Peaks in the position we are able to to
generate very simple user friendly
mutation reports for these particular
samples and on the screen in front of
you I have an example of a 1% mutation
in the Red Death and you can see that's
a very clear peak from the baseline at
that 1% mutation frequency versus the
wild-type peak in black on the left
there which is at 99% frequency so to
further demonstrate this this is our
life xhs chemistry and a dilution series
of horizon control samples and
specifically these two mutations that
we're diluting our resistance mutations
for lung cancer and colon cancer at the
top we have our EGFR t7 90
and mutation a resistance marker to
second-generation EGFR tyrosine kinase
inhibitor therapy but in an inclusionary
marker for third-generation
EGFR tki therapy being assertive and
here you can see a dilution from 5%
mutation frequency down to one point
five one point two five percent mutation
frequency and of course the wild-type
control on the right hand side you can
see that that mutant peak is clearly
detectable all the way down to that one
percent in the bottom we have our EGFR s
492 our mutation this is a resistance
mutation in colorectal cancer and
specifically colorectal cancers that are
on EGFR blockade therapy because the
position of this mutation is up in the
extracellular domain of EGFR and again
seeing that very clear mutant peak
underneath the red mu teasing mu T's
word and letters going all the way down
to 1.25%
and no signal detected on our wild-type
control so we've had some change in
guidelines of life so this is the new
draft guidelines from from Kappa is LC
and amp these draft guidelines were
released in November 2016 after a period
of consultation and there's been some
new recommendations so addition in
addition to EGFR and alchemy recommended
molecular markers for non small cell
lung cancer
they're now recommending in multi-gene
panels such as those that we provide
from a Gina bioscience on the mass array
to include be rough molecular testing
and erbb2 be rough is is focused around
just three three amino acid changes in
the BF gene and the erbb2 also known as
her two is different to those in breast
cancer and that it's not the
amplifications that we're looking for in
lung cancer but we're actually looking
for in short repetitive insertions in
erbb2 so we have designed our new HS
panel for lung to incorporate those
guidelines so you can see we're covering
be rough and the three major codons that
are relevant in lung cancer in be rough
broad EGFR
mutation detection from the single
nucleotide changes single missense
mutations such as la v 8r t 790 m of
course the c79 7s the new resistance
marker to AA cetera nib but also a broad
coverage of EGFR exon 19 deletions and
exon 20 insertions I haven't written out
all the mutations on this slide because
it makes for a very very busy slide but
we do have all of those specific
mutations available as a list on request
more than 40 deletions in exon 19 and 10
insertions in exon 20 in this particular
panel KS covering codons 12 13 and 61
the erbb2 in repetitive insertions we've
also included pik3ca so in total we have
five genes in this panel of more than 17
mutations and all of this is achieved
from a single multiplex PCR reaction
with a single multiplex PCR reaction we
have completely minimized the input DNA
required such that it comes down to
mathematical probabilities if you wish
to detect one percent mutation frequency
which is the limit of detection of this
chemistry well that's one in a hundred
and therefore you do need to put in at
least a hundred molecules in order to
see the one if you only put in ten
molecules I guess it will still work but
you'll only see one in ten at best so
it's always basically our import
material is now just down to
mathematical probabilities of getting at
that mutation allele into the PCR
reaction moving on from lung cancer
we've also seen new guidelines published
in jmd just last month so the new new
guidelines for colorectal cancer being
published last month after a
consultation and draft period last year
coming out from a SCP cap and Penasco
and the new recommendations for
colorectal cancer are extended Russ
testing so chaos an and rath analysis of
codons 12 13 59 61 1 1 7 and 146 and
also ranked recommending analysis of be
rough particularly the v600 v600e
mutation in these colorectal cancer
samples
now these draft recommendations came out
early last year and what we did early
last year is we actually extended our
existing anka focus panel which was on
our previous iplex pro chemistry and we
can we collaborated with dr. Sutton from
the Medical Foundation and we looked at
that we did a clinical study with
extended Russ and be roughing included
in 259 FFPE colorectal cancer samples
from the Midwest there and what we were
able to observe is that the extended
Russ mutations were identified in 41% of
cases and in fact the extension of Russ
so that is not just analyzing code on 12
and 13 of chaos but extending it out to
all of those different codons in both RK
r s and n Russ increased the the
detection of mutations by 15% in those
samples also observed that 12% of those
samples harbored be rough so by
extending our panel to the new
guidelines we had an additional 27%
mutation detection yield in these
particular samples now what we what we
have done is then taken that extended
Russ content and we've moved it on to
our new iplex HS chemistry so that in
addition to the extension increasing our
detection mutation detection lilt we can
also get that improved sensitivity so
that extended K Russ series the extended
n Russ series our b-raf v600e and two
other codons in be rough we've included
pik3ca we've also included the s for
known to our extracellular domain
resistance mutation in EGFR and in fear
of sounding like a broken record we have
also achieved this in a single multiplex
PCR reaction such that we've completely
minimized that input material and
achieving down to 1% mutation frequency
detection I'm going to allow dr. Sutton
to explain the the clinical outcomes of
increasing that sensitivity in both the
lung and colon colon panel
so we've moved on we've evolved as well
we're a technology provider that's
constantly evolving evolving from our
original 5% limit of detection and now
releasing our new I Plex HS colon and
lung panels achieving down to 1%
mutation frequency detection in these
clinical samples and we also do have our
ultra seek colon and lung panels which
allow liquid biopsy analysis down to
0.1% so with the mass array we are able
to achieve we are now releasing new
targeted panels to identify mutations of
known significance in both colon and
lung samples as I've said we've
completely minimized that sample input
material required coming from a single
PCR reaction we have robust assays that
are that are optimised for these highly
degraded and low-frequency heterogeneous
samples we have a very fast turnaround
time completely automated post PCR
processing and mass spectrometry
analysis allows us to achieve results in
less than eight hours and our
sensitivity we are able to detect more
than 50 mutations in these panels down
to as low as 1% mutation frequency so
I'll now hand it back to the moderator
and let dr. Sutton explain to you how
these panels perform in a clinical
environment
thank you dr. Erwin for that informative
presentation I will now turn the
presentation over to dr. Sutton
good morning to everyone thank you for
joining us
I've been working in the foundation now
for over 15 years and in the last few
years I had become the molecular
pathology director of the foundation and
before I launch into this discussion of
the mass array thought it would be a
good idea to kind of show you a little
bit about the organization that I
represent so that you know get a better
idea of the number of cases that we see
and our patient clientele that we see
basically the Medical Foundation is a
pathology group and reference laboratory
they served several hospitals over a
region we are also a blood processing
and distribution facility we have about
750 employees about 18 pathologists
we've had a couple of retirements but
we're also adding a couple more on so I
think we're at 17 now volume wise we do
a lot of anatomic pathology because we
serve several hospitals about 55,000
surgical is quite a few Merrill's in
psychology both non GYN and GYN we
collect blood it's in the neighborhood
of 25 to 30 thousand products collected
and distributed this year in all
throughout our system about six million
tests give or take and we've been in
this business quite a while we had our
hundred year anniversary back in 2012 so
this whole laboratory system we have our
central laboratory facility which is in
South Bend our former name was the South
Bend Medical Foundation you will also
see that it's kind of a we have two
names that are pretty much
interchangeable out there you may see us
as s PMF or the South Bend Medical
Foundation we have our central lab it's
in South Bend those are our major
hospitals and this facility this is in
this area but then we also reach down
into
central Indiana and also we have draw
site satellite laboratories and reach a
number of physician hostas ition offices
so it really is a large operation for
both anatomic and clinical pathology so
how did we start on this quest well it
began back in about 2012 and 2013 we
began to look for a new molecular
platform that would address this growing
need for broader mutation coverage in
common solid tumors this is when things
like the NCCN guidelines were starting
to evolve and um there was this need to
do more mutation analysis and well the
kits that were available then weren't
keeping up with what the literature was
really saying and what our oncologists
were frankly demanding of us as their
literature moved on and like many
laboratories at that time we were using
PCR based kits that could detect
typically like codons 12 and 13 and krad
be roughly 600 e and then the four exons
in EGFR our number of mutations in each
but as that literature literature went
forward we realized our clients wanted
and needed more to treat their patients
so how do we approach this problem well
we talked to some of our colleagues in
our region the st. Joseph's Regional
Medical Center that's one of two
hospitals in our system Memorial
Hospital South Bend that's actually now
beacon medical system at two major
hospitals and then we're also a South
Bend is the home of the University of
Notre Dame and we have some colleagues
at the Harper Cancer reach Research
Institute and we all wanted to do the
same thing we want to increase the
availability of medically appropriate
solid tumor mutation analysis and in
this community based medicine
environment we are not a big you know
academic teaching hospital these are all
community based
facilities we wanted to have this
testing available for our patients so we
worked with our colleagues at the Harper
Cancer Research Institute and they
sought out and were successful in
getting grant funding from the Walter
councillor Foundation and that allowed
us to partially supplement the cost of
the the analyzer the mass array analyzer
and also to supplement patient costs for
testing so it was really a win-win for
patients and also additionally the
Harper Cancer Research Institute was
quite interested in the ability to use
this equipment for their growing tumor
by a bio Bank so why did we pick the
Agena system well at this time this is
back and again about 2013 the hot new
science out there that was coming of age
for clinical laboratories was
next-generation sequencing and we look
at it very very hard but there were some
problems there number one I'm the lone
molecular pathologist in my group I
don't have a large bioinformatics group
to fall back on to help me with
interpretations same thing for the
computer assistance and infrastructure
that's really needed to set up and
validate a NGS laboratory and also that
was at a time where the NGS was growing
as well and and changing there are a lot
of updates going on in the technology
and I really felt that that project
would be extremely difficult if not
impossible for me and my group on the
other hand we still wanted this large
amount to greatly increase the number of
mutations that we could detect from a
single sample and that's why we went
with the master a platform has been an
outstanding decision for our
laboratories so we brought it in and
actually we brought the machine
in early 2014 and one of my concerns
about NGS is I felt like it could take
us easily over a year to validate it
with master a we brought it in and we
validated it in a few months it went up
quickly it performed robustly and we
really were able to get it up and
functioning and unlive clinically and I
thought a very good short amount of time
and when you consider that my
organization during that same time frame
was working to put in a new laboratory
information system I think that the
staff and my lab did an outstanding job
so what else can I say about this we wit
with the Aqua focus panel that covers
this 300 plus common mutations in KS in
raspy RF and EGFR and because we were
also wanting to add more for metastatic
melanoma we also added a kid extension
that covers some about 85% of the common
mutations in kids and the sensitivity of
this panel is as Darrell mentioned five
to ten percent very little fraction
although I will tell you that now having
worked with this for about well three
years now
there will be occasional cases that you
will be able to see and clearly call
below 5% but that's rare that is to me a
downside is when you get down below 5%
there will be cases that you will not be
able to confidently call the mutation
and just on the bottom and/or the bottom
side of that frame is just what the
analyzer looks like so how's this
project fared well it's done I think
very well it's been I think a boon to
patients in our community because we've
been seeing because they're screening
more patients for early lung cancers
we're seeing a lot of biopsies for lung
but also for colorectal adenocarcinoma
and yes for metastatic melanoma about
200 cases a year each of pulmonary non
small cell carcinoma and about 200
of colorectal carcinoma in about 30
cases a year metastatic melanoma we've
been working with the Aqua focus version
2 panel with the kid extension up until
2015 when we added the extended wrasse
and as dr. Erwin mentioned we have an A
MP poster on that data in 2015 showing
the extended raft and how that did pick
up an additional 15% of mutations that
were considered clinically significant
and we had that panel live again very
quickly so in early in my laboratory
Massa rates been a reliable workhorse
rarely down when we when it does go down
we can talk to the folks of the Geno
they can remotely remote into our system
and sometimes fix things but it's been
really a workhorse that is reliable and
in fact we've added more to it now we're
doing cystic fibrosis testing also we
added that to the platform as well and
when I learned last year that Aegina was
developing the iplex
high sensitivity with the one to two
percent allele fraction detection I was
very excited about this and here's why
I don't know how many in our audience
out there anatomic pathologists that I
am and at a time the anatomic
pathologists have found out both
surgical and psychologies as well as
these other things that I do clinical
pathology wise but all of us have seen
cases like this this is a photo
micrograph from a pleural fluid
psychology cell block a big group of
cells in the middle of the field is a
few cohesive adenocarcinoma cells and a
lot of other things it's got lymphocytes
and some needeth ileal cells in the
background but that's not a lot of tumor
and this is exactly the kind of case
where you look at you go wow I like to
see 10 to 20%
tomber visually when I assess cases
before going to the mass array and this
one really didn't have it but then I get
that phone call from the oncologist and
I'm hearing about how old please run
this because this patient they are
really sick they've got a high tumor
burden but they're so sick we don't want
to risk putting them through a biopsy
we've got tumor in this sample please
run it please run it so we ran it and on
the angka focused version three panel it
was negative for mutations in EGFR kfb
ref and again the sensitivity there's
five to ten percent and I have a
qualifier that I put on cases like this
and my sign out basically reminding the
clinician that there was not a lot of
tumor here if another sample from this
patient's cancer becomes available you
might want to test again but when this
study came up when we collaborated with
a Gina this was one of the cases that we
included and lo and behold when we took
the sensitivity down to 1% with the
iplex HF this case was positive for B
Rafi 600 e mutation and that result was
subsequently confirmed in a second
independent digital PCR assay now I went
and I looked at those original aqua
focus panel data to say can I see this
with this really there and no mutation
was called by the software but let me
show you what that review showed and
I'll first step back a minute and kind
of show those of you who have not seen
what the spectrum output is from
macerate dr. Erwin showed you some of
this but on the left hand side of the
screen we've got the wild-type which
does not show a second peak where the
mutant allele is and on the right hand
side you've got two different cases each
of which have a beer at these 600 e
mutation up at the top the beer F 1799 F
that's for forward is in well one that's
the particular PCR
action that has this particular mutation
detectable in it and it's part of a
four-plex basically that gives us a
total group of reactions that says yes
the PRF v600e is there and what's really
nice about this technology in addition
to getting these really quite robust
Peaks when they're there you see them
but you can also get an idea of the
variant allele frequency that's in your
specimen so this is actually two
different cases one of which had a 27%
mutation allele frequency in it and the
bottom a little bit higher peak or 39%
so I have found when I've compared to
other technologies technologies that
this data is roughly comparable to what
you get from say a pyrosequencing or an
NGS where you get an idea of how much
mutation is represented in this sample
so this is the kind of data that you get
now let's look at our particular case
okay up at the top that's the breakdown
of the four-plex for your bb wrap so you
can see what wild-type is and then the
different mutations that can be detected
with this particular assay and so then
move down into the two spectra with the
b-raf 1799 forward in well one there is
a very small mutant allele at a and I've
got a circle around it to show it to you
but when you look along that baseline
that's really not much above the
baseline prospectively the software
couldn't call it and even on review I
mean it's there I think that I
understand why the software didn't cover
it didn't call it and then on the bottom
when it's the second one the $17.99 r4
reverse there's supposed to be a peak
there and now well you may be mini
squint at it but really not much above
baseline so it's probably there but
prospectively with justice data I cannot
call this however
oops I went too far however we could see
it with the aplex HS and we could see it
when it was confirmed by the second
technology so this is a second case that
illustrates how powerful I think this
new new PC R configuration is this is a
core biopsy of a left upper lung lobe
nodule the needle core biopsy and you
can see in this close-up inset picture
that there is a small closed small
cluster a malignant cells there but
there's also a lot of stroma in the
background there's inflammatory cells
and there's really only a small portion
of this material that is represented by
tumor and even with Micro dissection
which we do we do we do hand dissection
to try to increase the increase the
proportion of tumor cells in any
material when we think that will help in
this case there's just not much tumor
there and our Alka focus panel showed no
mutations well interestingly to me this
was one of the ones that I call a game
changer when this case was in the study
that we did lo and behold there's an
EGFR la 58 our mutation and that was
compared confirmed independently by a
second digital PCR and those of you out
there who are doing these sorts of
mutations know again that's a mutation
this changes the type of treatment that
the patient will get that one is a
game-changer you don't want to miss an
EGFR la 58 our so this one made me stand
back and go okay one percent is a
improvement so I went back and I looked
at the original panel run data it was
called by the software with only a
medium probability of being a true
mutation
and here we are the Aqua focus spectrum
case there's where that box there is
where the mutant peak should be and then
it may be there you really can't see it
again it's not above baseline the bottom
frame on the other hand is from the
iplex HHS clearly showing a mutant peak
so we can pick this up at this
sensitivity level and give a spectra
that are readable and are robust which
to me is very impressive so in this
study that we performed we looked at a
hundred seventy nine cases of pulmonary
non small cell carcinoma which had an
adenocarcinoma component all the
previously detected mutations that we
saw with the eye flex or excuse me with
the aqua focus were there but we failed
an additional 17 cases about 10% so the
additional low-frequency mutations using
this more sensitive iplex hf chemistry
now I went back and I looked at all the
original spectra I confirmed eight
mutations I thought they were likely
there but just too weak to call two of
those for EGFR la 58 RS there were two
new low frequencies second mutations
that we hadn't seen the first go around
as well as five new K rats to n rats and
two new b-raf and one la 58 are
mutations and all of these new mutations
again we got the digital PCR in fact my
colleagues of the Jeana did this were
able to confirm all these new mutations
by the second independent platform and
when I broke out all the specimen types
didn't surprise me of the 17 cases
fourteen came from small tissue samples
needle core biopsy psychology cell
blocks where the frequency of tumor
cells in the population that you tested
was low so I thought this really showed
the
power of the iplex HS chemistry and it's
my plan to move our lung testing to this
now there was the second part of this
that we also did a similar experimental
design looking at colorectal
adenocarcinoma that has been previously
tested for chaos in rats and beer asked
on our previous are on our uncle focused
panel look at 143 cases once again if we
saw it the first time we saw it the
second time the previously detected
mutations were confirmed but we also
identified eight new mutations five of
which were a second low-frequency
mutation of different sites but again
when you think about treatment
potentially game changers three of these
were new mutations and they were all in
the RAF two and K rats and one an N risk
which potentially could change the
therapy for the patient so that pretty
much summarizes the work that we've done
on this as I mentioned my plan is to
bring in and validate the iplex HS
chemistry particularly for lung possibly
for colon as well just simply because I
look at this data and think that well to
serve my patients I think this is a
necessary step so I don't like missing
low-frequency mutations that might
change a patient's treatment so that's
pretty much the the data that I wanted
to show today I want to thank you all
for your attention but I also want to
mention one other thing and that is I
want to mention the members of my team
I've been I'm very proud to be a part of
the Medical Foundation and I want to
thank my administration dr. Simpson's
anyway I could not have done this
project without them they're not on here
but I want to collect thank also my
collaborative collaborators at the
University of Notre Dame but also
manager of the lab Kevin
and then members of the team that worked
very hard and learned this technology
and use it every week fact I've got my
master a sign out on my desk right now
that's Tammy ray Jon kiss
Tish and Jessica Dale my thanks to all
of them for your wonderful work and
thanks to you all for your attention to
me thank you Dr Irwin and got
perspectives for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green - and a button at the lower left
of the presentation window dr. Erwin and
dr. Sutton will answer as many questions
as time permits and the first question
is for dr. Irwin I'm confused about how
the mutant allele percentage in the pre
amplified sample is calculated if there
is a preferential numeral base extension
of the mutant allele that's enriching
the mutant in the amplified sample
compared to the original sample
can you explain briefly sure so with the
new I flex HS chemistry as you say we
are biasing towards the mutant allele
the generation of the the mutant allele
the bias that's introduced is
reproducible in that therefore it's it's
linear its and and it's reproducible and
then we can normalize back to the
original mutant allele frequency to
determine what the original mutant
allele frequency was in the sample so
we're achieving increased detection of
low frequency mutations but have the
capacity to then normalize that to
determine what the frequency was in the
in the initial sample okay the next
question is for dr. Sutton
what kind of FFPE extraction platform
are you using and is the I plus HS very
sensitive to the DNA quality we use a
hydrogen
FFPE kit so it's commercially available
and from my perspective I think we get
good quality DNA when we look at say
from the spectrophotometer measurements
um we don't run gels to look at quality
from that perspective we do this is
really part of a clinical part of it's
part of our clinical processes and
essentially we look at the quantity of
the DNA we did and we pretty much go
with that so I don't know how much I can
can really comment on in terms of
looking at the quality of the DNA per se
because we're not specifically asking
that question okay this next one and
this next one is short for dr. Sutton um
do you have if you have clinical outcome
on lower minor allele frequency cases
and outcomes for EGFR inhibitors therapy
and there are more parts to this
question so ask answered aspartyl I wish
I did this is part of the part of the
grant study that I noticed some of my
colleagues at Notre Dame are hoping to
get in the next phase of the grant but
unfortunately what I have found is that
often the treatment notes of the patient
which is what we're talking about here
are in the individual oncologists office
notes and that's not something that I
can readily access so I wish I had a
better answer for that it's a great
question and I agree this there it's
very pertinent to this discussion but
from my perspective it's not one that I
can readily get to the data okay and
this audience members the second part of
their questions are you looking at
clinical outcomes and finding these low
frequency mutations in other tumors etc
or do you think this is just purely a
sampling issue not representative of
tumor clone ality and hetero
nanti again I don't have the ability to
do the clinical outcomes part of this
from from from my laboratory I don't
have access to that clinical information
so I'd be hard-pressed to other than to
comment that I think a lot of what I see
is sample related but that's based on
anecdotal observation and not based on
clinical correlation with patient data
so I'd have to couch that in some
concern for interpretation I just don't
have the clinical data to match up cue
the next ones for dr. Erwin does someone
have experience using a dramatized pcr
method with this platform okay no not
that I know of we we use a very standard
just multiplexed five microliter pcr
with with this platform we haven't done
any droplet size PCR amplification okay
doctor earliest next limit for you to
what sample types can be tested with
these panels and I think I think dr.
Sutton can also weigh in but basically
almost any sample type basic hour
amplicon sizes are 60 to 80 base pairs
in length so we do need intact DNA down
at that very short fragmentation size so
this we find that this is robust of
course we can use buccal cells white
blood cells buffy coats we can use FFPE
samples fresh tissue fine needle
aspirates that have been put into FFP we
also do work on circulating cell free
DNA and circulating tumor cells and
potentially it would work on on cell
free DNA in urine as well if I may take
on that um in the clinical laboratory
the only sample type we are validated
for is formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue any other fixative we don't have
experience
Swift and currently acid decalcified
tissue blocks are also a cause for
rejection of the specimen because of the
DNA is just too degraded to get a good
sample from thank you this next point is
for both of you to maybe doctor sent you
one are we in first how long did it take
to generate results well we perform the
tumor FA once a week and essentially it
is in our laboratory I know they've
mentioned that you can go you can get
sample to answer in about eight hours we
have our process set up to go from
extraction of the DNA through to PCR
data acquisition to interpretation over
about a two day period
in terms of the ER interpretation we
have it set up where we do a two fold
where the technologist who generates the
data goes through the spectra goes
through the interpretation algorithm
that's actually quite user-friendly the
the software that a Gina has built into
this is easy to learn I felt I have
found that they go through it they give
me that result and then I go through it
independently and put both of those two
together so two different sets of eyes
look at the same spectra and come to the
same hopefully to save interpretation as
a quality check and the actual
interpretations is built into our
computer system there's a lot of
mutations here in this very large panel
all of that I wrote those
interpretations myself and they've been
essentially hard-coded into our
millennium cerner LIF such that when a
colon sample for example with a K rest
g12c mutation is entered in the
appropriate interpretation will fire for
that so that all of that work
the backside was work that I did for the
clinical laboratory and dr. Erwin T well
I think dr. Sutton has has answered it
quite well you're you're working with a
two-day process including extraction our
newest instrument does automate one of
the previously manual steps and that was
the the the DNA the cleanup after the
amplification the spotting and that does
accelerate things slightly or reduces
the the hands-on step that is required
which often requires people to take two
days to generate those results and we
have put in the chip prep module and we
have seen some economy in this as well I
don't have numbers in front of me but I
can tell you that the technologists
doing this assay love the load up and
walk away and I believe we're seeing
decreased error because of the control
you get through the spotting with the
automated equipment so I think the chip
print module which is our name for it
has been a nice addition to our lab
that's our name for it too so we're
we're using common term and terminology
well it looks like we have time for one
more question and this one's for both of
you also dr. Sutton maybe you could
weigh in first how many samples can you
typically test in a run well my run
today to give you an example is what we
call a three-chip run and this includes
a positive a negative and a no template
water control and I think we have well
here I've got it written in front of me
that we had we had about 10 colon cases
to lung cases in one melanoma case and
it went a little bit longer because we
also had some additional samples I think
there were our proficiency samples that
we had to add on so that made for a
three-chip run a usual run for us is one
or two chips
and we run typically five to maybe maybe
ten or twelve cases that are clinical
mutation cases for solid tumors a week
and dr. Ehrman would you let you weigh
in as well sure so we do have some
several different formats of the
instrument the chip prep module format
which we've been talking about with that
automation is a 96 format with our HS
panels on a 96-well chip that allows up
to 12 samples on a single chip so you
can do do 12 samples on a single chip on
either of the either of the panels so it
could be six colons and six lungs or so
on and so forth but you can also do
multiple chips as dr. Sutton mentioned
so you can you can depending on
thermocycler availability you can do up
to ten or even twenty chips on that
instrument and run chips in parallel
well thank you I would like to once
again thank dr. Erwin and dr. Sutton for
their presentations do you have any
final comments the only thing that I
would add is I I think the macerate has
been a wonderful addition to the
molecular pathology laboratory here and
I'm very happy to also mention that our
grant funding just got extended so I
hope I know more patients will benefit
from having this technology in our area
and that's a good thing I'd like to
personally thank dr. Sutton we've been
working together for many years
Aegina comes up with the technology and
then dr. Sutton works with us to show
how that works on clinical cases which
is an important part of our
understanding and our our our deployment
of this technology such that it's
relevant to the market so thank you dr.
Sahni you're very welcome thank you
again and I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by a Gina bioscience via the
contact information you provide at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor a Gina bioscience for
under
today's educational webcast this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on this
seating button at the bottom left corner
and follow the process to receive your
credits this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through October 26 2017 lab
routes will alert you via email and it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye